[Music]
thank you
so much everyone for sticking with out i
hope you have had a wonderful summer
school this year
i am animesh and i am uh going to talk
about uh
a sliver of reinforcement learning and
deep enforcement learning today
particularly what we are going to call
of policy
[Music]
i will introduce the ideas and then also
introduce
technical problems of where and how of
policy adult can be useful in continuous
control
drawing inspiration from your bodies
at the end we will have a bunch of time
for questions but please feel free to
type in your questions in q a
even during the talk and i'd like to
make this as interactive as possible
so let's get started
the broader idea
that we might have already seen
in
deep learning is that if you can put in
some structured model plus data and
compute
you essentially get high performance
both computer vision and natural
language sub domains have shown this
sort of progress rather monotonic
progress over the last 52 years
now you could even argue that a lot of
deep learning applications in vision and
natural language are essentially built
on three common ingredients
one could say that these are
large structured models
so they can have particular kind of
structured biases whether attention
transformers or
convolutional biases
in both of those cases you have
reasonably large open iid datasets and a
concise problem definition
and finally you can use distributed
deployment for both large scale training
and
influence
now if i compare this with intelligent
robotics of embodied ai where you have
to make sequential decision making
interactively
it turns out that
that all of these assumptions are easily
violated
if you look at deep reinforcement
learning often
the deep aspect of deep reinforcement
learning is not very deep
we are still using very small models the
datasets that we are using are not very
large definitely not comparable to
language and perception
and finally if you really think about
distributed compute or lat scale compute
often it's
limited to how you're going to generate
the data online rather than really
training a large complex model and
influence is fairly fast
now if you start thinking about building
a system interactive
decision making system you can think
about doing it in one of the tools
you can either
build in domain expertise
so if you think of conventional robotic
processes
you would build in a pipeline which uses
perception planning and then control
all the other way around you could go
to
a data-driven method where you can
basically think of building some sort of
end-to-end system
to
[Music]
do decision making
now the problem is both of these systems
or both of these paradigms have their
own shortcomings
on one side you need experts which may
not be easily available and importantly
the solution itself may not be
generalizable so there is a performance
versus flexibility data
on the other
using data first of all there's a
problem of computational sustainability
uh
increasingly large models are not well
visible
data itself may not be accessible
and then even then so we will have out
of distribution units
so now it's basically the question that
neither achieves generalization at scale
so what do we do
[Music]
so if you think about this from a
perspective of core ideas in machine
learning as they have evolved over the
last fifty two hundred years
you can trace it back from philosophy to
psychology to machine learning and even
deeper and almost all of them argue that
you need particular kind of inductive
biases to achieve generalization in fact
they even argue that
there is no notion of generalization
without structure you have to
provide some structure to the problem to
even define and achieve some perception
so now using these thesis that we need
structure and data just data may not do
the truth
and structure itself may be domain
knowledge inductive biases symmetries
priors and so on and so forth
of course at the same time data itself
will be
uh online or offline simulated or new um
labeled or sensitive
[Music]
so now if we start looking at
well structure and data
we can look at different kinds of
structures that are commonly used these
days and this is by no means a survey of
these kinds of structures but just to
give you a sense that
these pipelines consist of different
ideas
from low level structure to let's say
sequentiality mortality or independence
to having higher level abstractions such
as attention
then there is ideas at the level of
architecture on how to use transfer
learning from supervised language
providers
and then finally structure in the last
functions using contrastive networks
but now let's look at let's focus on
ideas here for reinforcement
so at this point by this point in
december school i don't need to
introduce the concept of reinforcement
but just as a refresher you can really
think of this as a mechanism where
you have an object which is a markov
decision process the goal is to find a
mapping policy from stage to action
so you get some sort of input the agent
itself is a model that has some sort of
learning rule
updating through and outputs an action
that action is provided to an external
environment which in turn results next
day and some sort of utility already
working
in the context of robotics the state can
be
an image or robot state
the agent could be
let's say your favorite new network
and actions could be a topic
now the problem is
that these sort of architectures have
gotten us very far indeed there are very
interesting and impressive results
in this domain
however if you compare compare these
results qualitatively to what we see in
intelligence it still leaves a lot to be
done in particular if you look at let's
say an elephant
the elephant doesn't really know how to
use its trunk when
when it is born as baby
but it has the right biases to use
the trunk and learn to use it very
quickly often within days if not
others
and similarly
we have the ability for a remarkable
ability to learn open-ended broadcasts
right so we are not learning with
defined tasks that are all suitable in
that sense
and neither of those things have been
achieved at scale or at least at scale
yet
so the question really that we should be
asking ourselves is what sort of
structured biases do we need to achieve
this sort of generalizable autonomy in
decision making or open-ended decision
energy
to understand this i would invite you to
think about another agent slightly in
detail so aside from the generic picture
let's start thinking about how this
might work
you might first of all have a perception
system where an observation is actually
processed uh
some abstract state of subjection
often this is a very
let's say heavy to learn
part of the model where the majority of
the effort goes in converting
observation into an easier to process
once you have a state you might have a
reactive control the controller may
itself output some abstract action that
can
be decoded into google
notice for example that you can have a
deep reinforcement learning policy
running at 10 to 20 thirds outputting
let's say only the position of the end
effector or the arm while the action
decoder here would be running an
analytic inverse kinematics composer
that converts the end effector into the
full joint state
uh this action decoder doesn't always
have to be elevated it could also be
there
in addition to the reactive policy the
agent might have other objectives or
other models one is a transition model
the other one can be a value function
and depending on how you use them you
would be either in a planning or a
learning regime
and of course you will have an update
rule to update the agent and the models
now to solve this problem you can
attempt to solve this problem in
multiple ways
two particular let's say broad
definitions of algorithms can be either
on policy
and off policy
so within the on policy regime what you
are doing is you are interacting with
the environment and simultaneously
updating your policy iterator or the
agent that is interacting with the
environment
is
being updated through your objective
and the difference key here between on
policy and off policy is
that in off policy setting
the agent is learning from a buffer of
data
which can be collected through
interaction but it is not necessary that
the interaction policy is the same
policy that is being learned
so if you notice the key difference here
is the agent is by a agent
in the other side the agent is behavior
and the behavior policy is the one that
is acting and it could indeed be
different
so just look at this in detail you have
some behavior policy that is acting in
the environment
this can result in data that we store in
our buffer
we can use this buffer
to learn
some value function in this particular
case let's say a q function
i can use my q function to come up with
a new policy today
and then i can continue doing this
notice it is not necessary that after
the iteration
the behavior policy is updated to the
new production
so that's the key difference of off
policy rll from one possibility
now
i showed you this picture
and what i'm going to do today is to
actually invite you to
look at each of these blocks and see
if there is structure that we can
provide to be a bit more efficient or a
bit more smart about how we are doing
this decision
so first question to ask here can build
in the replay doctor where is this data
going to come from especially if it's
going to be a scale
and even more importantly if it is going
to be from well real robots
and if you have such data can we use
this more efficiently
in the context of robotics
again comparing robotics to vision
language vision and language have very
large datasets
of interaction often
scaled or often
[Music]
often collected from
the web however
robotics or robot learning in general is
yet to witness such a substance because
there is no web scale data set
for robots people have attempted
creating small data sets
and the problem is often that first of
all you need solutions
of diversity diverse time so the same
topic same
problem put an object inside a bin can
have diverse styles of solutions you can
throw the object in you can push it in
or you can sort of slide it in
you also need often dexterity because
human world is built for interaction by
humans so robots with only let's say
parallel geographers may or may not
always be sufficient
you need dexterity to achieve a variety
of tasks or interact with many objects
in the world
and then of course you mean scale we
need many problem instances many users
and diversity of both success and
payload
now doing this
is generally very hard for robotics
because the solution cannot be labeled
you need to actually demonstrate
and this is where the insight is that we
can use cloud sourcing but this time
around we need a mechanism to do it at
school
so we have built this system which is
scalable which we call the robot
it allows a user to essentially use
consumer-grade devices like a phone
and you can do data collection via a
very simple video interface like zoom so
nothing is running on your computer
locally
and essentially you're computing you're
doing this in six star
and you can do this from a variety of
different locations uh both in
simulation and on the loop
we've built the system to be fairly
robust that we were
able to run this system
[Music]
off of network in the alps from macau to
princeton across atlantic or across
pacific
so at the time when we did this about
three years ago three and a half years
ago uh this was one of the largest data
sets available
for
real robot interaction
from humans
so of course a bunch of data was
available algorithm
but this was one of the first ones to
scale the data sets up
to the uh to the order of hundreds of
hours
rather than
let's say a few tens of dollars
now even if you have this data whether
from robutter or from a different
mechanism
one question would still exist well
what do you do with this data can you
actually learn
uh anything meaningful from just
external experiences
so now the problem setting is
very similar to off policy
but with a slight difference that you
are now offline so there is no loop
closure so you can do data collection so
there is some behavior agent that is
doing a data collection through
interaction
you have this data pathway now you can
interact with this bucket but not with
the environment and you have to do this
policy learning uh completely in in
sandbox in a sense and that is why it is
awkwardly
and then you can take this policy or
learn outcome and deploy it on a system
now interestingly
this is a gene that has of course been
very popular but often uses only
computationally generated
which is often very different
qualitatively from real robot of yields
which does not have reward structure and
often requires complex manipulation with
multimodal policies
one way to think about this please when
you have large data sets
there is multimodality in both failure
and success there are many ways to fail
and many ways to succeed
so
simple doing supervised learning
so in this case we proposed an algorithm
which we call
types
and what we are basically arguing is
that there exists a lot of multimodality
in the data
however
we can think of the policy as a
two-stage process a two-stage process in
the sense that there is a low-level goal
condition imitation controller
the goal selection mechanism is a
state-to-state
generated model
and the low-level goal condition
imitation controller is a unimodal
controller so you can really think of it
as that the complexity of multimodal
distribution modeling is now
on the level of goal selection while
given a goal
policy can be locally focused
so one way to think about this will be
that if i am at current state st the
orange ball and i want to go to
some group i can sample a next state
or a local minister
i can select that mixtape based on a
learned value function
and use that
local goal
as a
as an input to the low level
communication computer
this indication controller does not need
to look far out ahead
this is equal into thinking about how
you would plan to do long-term tasks so
think about going to the airport if you
are going to the airport you might think
of intermediate states you want to be in
maybe get to the training station take a
plane x up until point station x get
down and go on but you don't need to
think about all of the footsteps or the
planning that you will do to achieve
each of those things
throughout the process you do that
locally
so now you're planning on different
levels of abstractions kind of things
and
this algorithmic decomposition is in a
sense achieving a very similar
effect
so now what this enables you to do is
learn interesting multi-step tasks
purely from a fixed data set
in both of those cases the task is very
simple to grab the can and put it in one
of those steps this is a very hard task
in general
if you want to do it with a single
reward function
and behave with learning or even
off policy area like backspin stream
queue learning seems to fail because of
dataset distribution chips
while what we see is our method can
achieve the solution fairly efficiently
and
i don't know if it's visible
but
if you play the video slowly it is
providing you these goal selection
mechanisms where it is predicting what
the goals could be the goals don't
themselves have to be
physically viable they just need to be
something that the robot can achieve
and interestingly you can do this also
purely with image statement in this
particular case we did self-supervised
learning for key points uh as
representation and we found that you can
also do this end to end with image
states with a representation that is
domain independent so we are not doing
pose explanation or anything you're just
learning key points in this 2d video
and the interesting thing is that we
were able to achieve about 40 percent
success rate on this task which is
surprising because uh remember you are
you're basically not interacting with
the environment and they're able to do
this with of the order of 100 to 200
right so going back to the picture of
off policy rll i was asking you
this question where is this data going
to come from and can you use it more
efficiently so what i did was we showed
that if you use crowdsourcing you can
get expert human data rather than
let's say a heuristic policy builder
and you can use
off policy rl using let's say generative
models from states to
capture
however the second question still
remains of
how can we use this modification
well i already said right that
data in robotics
exists and robodog by no means was the
first one uh it has existed for at least
20 plus years but often these systems
were very small scale
the reason was well robot data is much
more expensive than other communities
so there's a number of algorithmic ideas
which allow us to do what we call data
augmentation essentially what we are
saying is
that if we didn't do augmentation within
the same fixed buffer or add new data
points then
performance can improve substantially
and two particular examples of this sort
of data augmentation are
hindsight experience required which is
essentially goal relatable
or you can also do randomization for
particular kind of structure
randomization for input relabeling which
is the observation
and both of those result in
substantial performance groups
both of those mechanisms of why or how
they are doing data augmentation
in both of those cases are commonality
energies
for example in hindsight experience and
play
what we are doing is we are taking some
projectives
and replacing the goal
uh with a different goal and arguing
that this trajectory was
built for or trying to achieve this
notice that the goal is independent of
underlying dynamics
similarly when we do visual
relabeling
the function that is doing the rendering
often is independent of the underlying
dynamics while preserving the key
information that you need to control
if you take this unified view you can
actually really think about this that
the
process is implicitly exploiting the
independence of causal mechanisms which
is guiding the transition
in fact if you can identify this causal
mechanism then you can do
much more principle
and more efficient data augmentation
and this is what we call counter factual
data augmentation where the idea is that
essentially there are a number of
variables that are evolving over time in
this observational system
you want to identify local causal
mechanisms that are independent and if
you can do that then you can essentially
do a
swapping of data in a combinatorial
sense and create in effect out of
distribution data sets uh which would
enable much better generalization
now just to give you an example what i
mean
think of a very simple example of uh two
walls interacting uh on uh williamstown
let's say i only give you two data sets
each of the balls what you see is a
trajectory let's say a five point
trajectory
and you have two data points
now the question i'm going to ask you is
given this data step do you think
that
this data point is a valid or reachable
at least think about your answer type in
type it in q a if you want but
think about why and if yes
let's say i would argue this is possible
one way to think about this would be
ball one orange one and ball two blue
b2 from scenario two are technically
independent they never interacted with
each other so in principle i think they
take these two independent instances and
put them together to create a new
potential imagined instance and because
they never interacted with each other
this is a viable solution or a viable
data
given the evidence
now on the other hand if i ask you is
this viable
well in this case the answer would be no
because
in my data set let's say a data set of
two points i've never shown you that
this is possible i've never shown you
evidence of collision and you don't know
what happens when trajectories glasses
or balls cross each other we need
evidence of possibility
and this idea can be generalized think
of a robot with two arms interacting in
common shared workspace now if i tell
you that they can do these tasks
independently and i ask you
is this alternating behavior possible
with shared workspace the answer is well
yes because in principle they can share
the workspace as long as they are
independent
on the contrary is this handover
possible well in principle it's possible
but i don't have any evidence to say yes
or no because now they are interacting
with each other which breaks the
implicit assumption of local causality
between causal independence between the
two forms
now the question is essentially we are
arguing that we can do data augmentation
in a more principle sense using model
field
but the key trick here is to understand
that we are not trying to identify
causal independence completely globally
in fact in many of these trajectories
there may not be a global causal
increment
let's say you do majority of the tasks
in a two-handed set up independently but
the end of the trajectory you touch each
other in principle the whole thing will
become
causally dependent
so what we are really after is what we
call local further independence rather
than global consequences
so essentially what we are saying is
a global model
of cause and dependence
connects variables through time to each
other using structural equation models
for dependent structure
we are interest instead interested in
essentially a causal model that only
looks like a
neighborhood in space and time
this is a very key insight looking at
only a neighborhood in space and time
you can actually use uh or leverage the
causal independence that would otherwise
not exist in a global scale
but where do these models come from how
can we learn these methods
going back to the billiards example we
can think of
let's say a very simple setup where i
gave you this uh two-ball setting where
the states faces their positions and the
gospels
and now
essentially
while i know globally they are not
local i can look at this and look at
this jacobian given a current state
and look at the fact that the jacobian
is blocked diamond
the jacobian being blocked diagonal
locally essentially is telling me
that in the current state and in the
neighborhood
these two
entities are independent
and of course this jacobian can be
learned as an attention mask
in dynamics learning
now you can use this idea to identify
possible independence and then you can
do something very similar what we did in
the example where you can take two
examples and mix and match the values of
each of the entities to create
combinatorial data
this is exactly what we did so this is a
very simple data set where we the task
is to push a block to
[Music]
a particular position
and in this case if you use a vanilla
hindsight experience which is an after
policy algorithm with ssc soft activity
you can solve this task as you see in
the green zone green curve
but if you can add
count of actual data augmentation on top
of this while doing offline of policy
problem
you can improve efficiency in a sense
that you can achieve
same
kinds of
success rates with 2x less than
and this gap becomes much more apparent
if you have a harder task let's say you
have to do the same things for multiple
projects and in this case not only are
you more efficient but we also observe
that you solve or you achieve
higher performance
if there is a limit on
so in this case notice that the x axis
is 30 x most samples compared to 300 000
samples
in the curve
so really the takeaway here was that
counterfactual data application folks
apart
and if you can do this correctly uh
you can basically make your algorithm
whether offline or online
more efficient
i would like to take a minute of pause
here and ask you if there are questions
uh you do have two questions um in the
chat
and so i'll
read them out since you can't um
so what do you from question from samuel
what do you think of the idea of data
sets of tasks environment instances used
in meta reinforcement learning for
example in the form of a data set of
simulator parameters are you excited
about specific recent or upcoming data
benchmarks in this space
uh
this is a very open-ended question i
would like to give a brief answer right
now and i will leave this question later
in general the data sets that we create
in meta reinforcement learning or in any
sort of simulated setups usually we are
creating tasks not solutions
that's one problem two remember at least
so far the evidence or the empirical
evidence dictates that solving
tasks
has required careful engineering of
reward functions
which is often basically equivalent to
providing a particular class of solution
to the agent often we are not using
reinforcement learning to discover
new classes of solutions that we did not
know about
uh and and i think so far we have not
seen a lot of evidence of doing that
using these multitask setups to do that
would indeed be very exciting uh i would
like to revisit this problem of this
question towards the end of the talk i
do have a big moment kill that might
answer this question slightly better
great
um
okay so the next question comes from
so in in iris how are demonstrations
collected for
s underscore zero greater than s
underscore g i'm sorry i'm a non-expert
here okay and then in parentheses from
the buffer or by the agent just acting
uh in in is out uh the paper itself we
used both human collective data and
retrained policies to collect
in both of those cases the idea was that
we want to use human data which we have
found in our work to be qualitatively
different from
let's say offline
rl data sets where the data comes from
uh pre-trained voices the human data is
often more noisy and has much more
multi-modality both in
let's say failure and success modes
which is usually not a feature of
algorithm generated data
did i answer your questions
we'll let them confirm
uh let's continue and maybe maybe we'll
come back to question answers uh again
in a few weeks after that
so one of the things that we were also
thinking about
was this idea of actually discovering
causing structures so in this case or at
least in uh in the contractual data
augmentation case
the causal structure was fairly simple
and the variables were more often than
not given
so we have also worked on ideas of
building
uh
unsupervised or self-supervised
discovery of causal structure for
domains where variables may not even be
known for instance when you are
simulating slots but the underlying
simulator may have a very high
dimensional fem representation but what
you want is a reduced order
let's say
uh representation of this
object with let's say 10 key bodies and
we want to build a causal structure
where the causality is
connectivity structure within the fabric
so that was one aspect of it
now if i
put my attention to a different aspect
of the off policy but also
let's assume you did all the things you
basically needed to do during the
during the learning from the buffer you
still need to actually deploy our policy
on
a system and especially if the system is
a realistic system this deployment would
actually be fairly expensive so
currently what happens is you do this
sort of offline policy learning
you learn
from a fixed data set then you deploy
this
now
deployment is the only real evaluation
of the policy and it can often fail
currently there is no mechanism to say
please don't fail
essentially it can fail in critical
situations this is just a joke where
one of the demos failed uh
you know in a live conference
and currently the pipeline would be if
it is working cool if it is not then
you're back to the drawing board and
built the elephants
now
this is a problem that is much more
evident in mission critical systems
where we need to evaluate behavior
before we can deploy these systems and
safety needs to be confirmed during
deployment
so
now think of a system like this where
you just bought a robot it knows how to
stand and you want it to run
the only thing is you are saying that go
do whatever you want to do just don't
break the the robot is ten thousand
dollars or whatever eight thousand
dollars and then uh repeated failures
are sometimes costly and maybe even
infeasible because you can break
so just don't fail in this case it could
mean that just don't fall down as long
as you learn to walk it's completely
fine
and this again the setting is not
limited to
let's say regular promotion it can be
anything you can basically say that
if you're trying to pass a cup of water
or learning to try to move a cup of
water on the table try not to spill it
everything else is stable
so in this case you can really think of
it like this that
assigning this sort of safety constraint
or understanding failure is very simple
if you just say do not fail and that
failure has very simple semantic meaning
uh it's very analogous this particular
plus one or zero
now you can really think of this as a
constraint objective where you're
interested about tasks but you are
basically saying that there is a
constraint on the sanction the
probability of failure given the current
policy
should be less than some value
if you really think about this
particularly in terms of uh let's say
it's possible setting then essentially
you can think of this
safety constraint as yet another value
function you can really think of this as
a safety value function and you're
basically arguing that there are two
kinds of value that you're
simultaneously estimating one is the
value of uh
let's say the reward and the other one
is a value which is in effect measuring
distance to failure and you want to make
sure that is always within certain time
so just going back
to remind you that this problem is yet
again an off policy algorithm problem in
the offline setting where you are now
estimating not just the task value
function but also the safety value
function
right so you have safety constraint
and and now you can do the usual sort of
the formulation where i'm interested in
estimating these value functions
now you could very easily create this
sort of uh algorithm where okay would
this
put this constraint as a lagrangian and
then
estimate these
value function changes
but the problem is especially with a
fixed data set the value function
estimation error particularly for the
constraint could be wrong
think about like this if you remember q
learning
you're basically estimating q learning
from a fixed data set
where you're sampling uh q from let's
say
a previous estimate or iterate of the q
function which we call q target
and the objective is to maximize or
minimize this function of this error
essentially which is called the td
but the minimization happens on a
different dataset the dataset collected
by the behavior policy and this is what
results in what you would call
distribution mismatch
so in a sense that you can have a true q
function and the estimated
q function could be very off depending
on what states have you seen the samples
have not existed in that term
so in this case because we are
interested in estimating some sort of
safety
just think about like this if the safety
function q
[Music]
is
a measure of distance to failure
right so
we want to maximize this value function
in a sense so what you can really think
of it like this that at any point in
time
i want to
maximize the probability of safety or
minimize the probability of failure
either however you determine
and in this case
conservatism would mean that i want to
make sure that at any point in time the
estimate even the erroneous estimate
and the distribution of error or
distribution of mismatch is still
safe safe in the sense that there is
there's a probabilistic guarantee that
you will not fall into the pit
regardless of what you're doing
exploration for the task
and you can do that by doing uh a trick
called conservative q learning where you
can add
a regular exit which can push the
estimated q function
up in this case which is basically
saying that you want to overestimate the
safety critic function rather than
underestimating it at any point
so now with this regularizer and i'm not
getting into the details of how this
regularizer is constructed from
but what it allows you to think about
this
it allows you to make sure that the
constrained q function is
overestimated always
and if it is indeed true
in your learning algorithm
then your algorithm at inference time
becomes fairly simple you can sample an
agent from
action from the environment
you can check if that action is uh
matching the safety threshold if it does
then you actually pass it through the
environment if it doesn't then you
sample a different action from them
interestingly
you can prove things about this
framework
importantly you can prove two things one
that the constraint of safety is met not
only during the final policy but
importantly during training so
uh it is very important to say that
even if you don't know how to run yet
this framework can prove or show that
the number of times you will fall is
bounded
and two because you're solving a
constraint problem it is expected that
there will be a loss of performance and
we can quantify that difference and we
are arguing that adding this constraint
does not necessarily affect sample
efficiency learning rate
is still the same
so
you can now do this task where let's say
the robot is learning to push
a block without topping it
toppling would basically result in a
failure and immediate independence
you can now try to do this task or a
constrained task with a number of
algorithms a base rl algorithm
constraint policy optimization ensemble
to learning and then csc which is the
conservative state typically
interestingly the task performance is
roughly the same or at least not
surprisingly different but when you look
at the number of
occlude failures over time we notice
that cumulative failures are far fewer
in the case of conservative estimation
so initially all methods fail same
number of times but the policy learns
that the same failure should not occur
again
and the same
could also be repeated for a different
domain let's say walking to running this
time around and we see exactly that we
can achieve
more than two x gap in total number
failures needed towards before we can
let's say arrive at some sort of
convergence for
the policy movement
now so far we said that you can do this
purely in an offline setting
where the evaluation happens only in
simulation but policy evaluation often
is very expensive especially on the real
robot can we do better with real robot
settings
what we can do here is we can train
until convergence we can deploy in the
real robot and if we fail we can add all
of the data that we have seen so far to
the data set and train again
so we are now basically saying that we
are adapting the algorithm to the real
system where
any time we see a failure we stop
inference we go back we fix our policy
and come back
and in this case we can now show that
even from csc we can reduce the policy
uh to
let's say deployment guidance is seen
by yet another two links so if you just
remember we went from 150 to 50
errors in
accumulation and now we can bring that
number down to 20 or even
high tens
with guided
guided
domain specific guidance on what
failures are
and doing so allows us to learn directly
on the real robot which is a very
important thing to understand because
now we have a practical framework which
can learn to do interesting things where
the number of catastrophic failures can
indeed be bounded ahead of them
so so this is what we talked about
interestingly
if you look at off policy io in general
there is a lot you can do even in other
aspects for example when we do deep
learning or deep file we often assume
that the
structure of value functional policy
will often be a simple removal but why
is that required
we found in our world that using a
different architecture particularly a
resonant group can improve performance
by up to 2x or allow us to solve
problems which were under not solvable
this gives memory uh
into the policy structure which improves
performance
we checked uh for a very simple
experiment across different algorithmic
domains and environments and we found
that this idea of intense other dense
connections in our helps to
further we have almost always assumed
that the utility function of the value
function should be computed with the
building block
this problem is essentially solving an
infinite horizon problem but in practice
you may not always want to solve an
incidentalizing problem
think about like this when you're
solving a take-home exam you may have
the liberty to
solve the problems one by one
however
when you are solving the same problem
set in a
timed one-hour setting during a midterm
you may want to solve easier problems
first
and and time or time remaining would
change the nature or exploration
strategies or even the final optimal
policy function
so we've proposed a new framework which
we call sea leveling see here is a
different kind of utility function which
we call cumulative accessibility
which inspect measures some notion of
reachability in an environment given a
time horizon and using this parameter h
i can use multi-gold multi-modal horizon
aware solutions directly in the system
just flagging that we're um you have 10
minutes remaining
thank you so much
yeah so it's up to you um you can
continue on with the slides or you can
yeah okay i think i'll continue with
part of it uh there's a bunch of things
that i do want to still talk about for
five minutes and then we will switch to
questions
so so far i talked about only the off
policy part but do remember there's a
lot of structure in reinforcement
learning even in other aspects not just
off policy
for example
if you are doing model based methods
then you could argue what should the
structure be for the transition model
we have found
that
hierarchical structures in the model
allow you to capture discrete and
continuous distributions or this latent
variable simultaneously
which in principle allow you to make
discrete and continuous decisions which
is a key problem in task and motion
planning in continuous computing
similarly
when we are learning these transition
dynamics we don't need to limit
ourselves to just prediction
in fact we can have something like a
task aware objective
we found that if you can do a task aware
objective
you can
do simultaneous representation learning
and better modern learning with either
less data or
you can solve slightly harder problems
where many of the dimensions of the
observation would be given
similarly
not only that
the input representations matter right
we assume that we can do end-to-end
learning but even end-to-end structure
matters here
in continuous control we found
that pre-training for self-surprise
representations uh of states helps
learning multiple tasks after the fact
in this case we train self-supervised
representations of vision and dutch uh
in the pre retraining phase and then
solve new tasks after the fact
notice that the model in general is much
more heavier in terms of number of
parameters in the perception module
anyways the policy module is often very
likely
this structure is not limited to input
but it is also
evident in output
think about like this that if the choice
of action space is choosing correctly
then
exploration becomes easier and transfer
across variable dynamics also becomes
easier in this case we showed that for
robotics using task space impedance
control
as a policy action space is a much
better control space than controlling
direct indicator or
joint class and then you can train from
images in simulation and go to the real
robot without doing
any data augmentation or data analysis
in fact you can even learn this action
beforehand and you can
use this learned action decoder as a
mechanism to do
low level or lower dimension abstract
action to control our higher dimension
control so in this case we found that a
two dimensional input controller for a
seven dot arm allowed users to do daily
operation much faster
and finally this idea of using the right
action spaces is not limited to again
robot manipulation we found that you can
do the same for like example motion
where again if you choose the right
attack space in this case the centroidal
space one way to think about this is
when you're walking you should only be
really thinking about where where your
head is and all of the limbs will fall
into place
so if there is one thing that you take
away from today's start
please let me do this
that there's a lot of structure
in
how we solve reinforcement learning
problems there's a lot we can do
in
uh
in
different aspects of how we are solving
uh decision making problem particularly
using rl in continuous control
often we take many of the problem
formulations such as
should we use q learning for artificial
inwards in infinite horizon should we
use particular kinds of architectures as
actually
we should be questioning those
assumptions and figuring out what
structured biases would help
in uh reinforcement
in general we have seen
the marginal value of creating the right
structured devices
creating quantum leaps
in other domains of applied ai
and i'm definitely of the belief that
robot learning
is in dire need of new ones
with that
i do want to say that despite the fact
that i only focused on one aspect of my
research today
as a group we study
broader questions of reasoning and
control in the body of systems where we
are interested in underlying learning
representations for our models bodies
discovering them from what causes
mechanisms and then thinking about how
all of this can be deployed together
with that
i'd like to thank you all for giving me
the privilege of your time and
i'm i will be able to share some of
these slides later today
[Music]
and i will include
the papers that we discussed which can
be centered here the papers that we
discussed uh today
and i'm happy to take questions now and
i'll also be hanging out later
to chat with you guys one on one
great animation thanks so much and
thanks for the offer of the slides of
their number one request from this
year's school
um why don't we take um
two questions and then we do have the
faculty mixer next so you can have the
opportunity to actually see the speaker
and talk to them in person for their
questions so first one talking about
data augmentation do you use analytical
inverse kinematics to add more data
points by wiggling some joints if so how
much would be the performance gap
between sweeping all the reachable space
to learn the kinematics
so that's actually a very neat insight
we have found that both random and
structured data augmentation helps
in
in simple cases creating
random
let's say random new data points where
you can create new data points for any
detector
in the nearby states and then solving
inverse kinematics for getting the joint
joint configurations would be a great
idea
we did this or something like this
in a paper called s4rl
and we found that
something very simple
such as that does indeed improve a lot
of performance however it is worth
noting that doing any sort of
randomization can only be done
especially in this kind of settings like
gaussian randomization can only be
creating
let's say coverage in the modes that you
have already seen
while what counterfactual data
augmentation can do is
can allow you to create new modes of
data that will not even in
the dataset so in principle
sound factual data augmentation is
principally a slightly better more
stable way to do this however do note
that adding gaussian noise is orthogonal
and can still be combined with kind of
actual recognition
great thank you and the last question of
the day hindsight experience replay
specifically targets sparse reward
settings and it is rather hard to tune
for other environments also it is fixing
its target for the whole episode is
counterfactual data augmentation able to
adapt better to other environments or
did you try experiments with dynamic
goals example changing within an episode
that's actually a very very good
question so the sparse reward
observation is indeed the correct one
where
uh
it is in in effect built for
uh environments where you don't have a
lot of reward signal hence hindsight
experience replay allows you to
learn to reach new goals implicitly
we explicitly focused on very similar
settings now the second part of the
question was did we experience or did we
look at problems where you can have
multi-step goals or sequentiality of
these things or dynamic goals in a sense
let's say following a spotlight kind of
thing
what they found is
it can indeed be very useful the
original coda framework was
in some places formally lacking and we
have since
expanded on that framework with a new
model called
model based product which uses or
relaxes some of the assumptions in coda
and allows you to generate
some of this data rather than just doing
swapping and we have found that in
principle it could achieve
uh
let's say
the problem setting of multiple bits
however we have only evaluated it on
fairly simple settings this is a
reasonably new word uh additional work
or additional exploration in that domain
would indeed be very cool uh the code
would be out even i would love to hear
from you guys a few times
thank you animash thank you for taking
those questions and thanks so much for a
great lecture
[Music]
you